The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
MARK HARVEY: Good
evening everybody.
My name's Mark Harvey.
And I'd like to welcome
you to this concert.
And this is the first of a
whole series of concerts.
I hope you have
the program there,
The Art of the
Improvisor series.
We have many fine
groups coming up,
including one led by Phil
Scarff in about 2 1/2 weeks,
over at the wall auditorium
up that way a little bit,
and then two more
wonderful groups.
This is a concert series in
conjunction with a class that's
going on this semester
called musical improvisation.
So we thought that it would
be an interesting idea
to have a concert
series and also
invite the people from
the artistic groups
to come into the
class and present
their particular approach
with the students.
And I see a lot of
the students here,
so thank you for coming out.
This is great.
And all you other
folks, we appreciate
you coming out on a cold night.
It always seems to be a
cold night when we do this,
but we're very happy to do it.
This is called FiLmprov, which
means film and improvisation.
And we're going to
start with improvisation
with our musical group,
for a musical set.
We'll just have a brief
pause, and then we're
going to have the films of Kate
Manson with us, now transformed
into a pit orchestra.
So you'll see us in
two different guises.
So we hope it's not too much
of a shock to see that change.
So here we go.
We're going to play something.
[MUSIC PLAYING]